[Musique]
sara jade tient bien
j'ai tout de suite vu que c'était un
garçon qu'elle a su agen 90 dont et puis
je vais te dire j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un
avoir des gros bras comme ça tu fais du
sport toi qu'est ce tu fais comme sport
c'est voir comment tu en fais quoi sert
la refais voir au civil juste juste au
foie
qu'est ce que t'es fort c'est ton petit
frère cadet est lui aussi ses bosquets
ya alors c'est toi qui gagne c'est
formidable
viens voir selon adage entendre les deux
parties bienvenus
qu'est ce que tu attends une seconde non
vous n'allez pas poster que voilà alors
[Applaudissements]
qu il dise en quelle poster tes un petit
garçon tout seul tu des frères et des
soeurs tout ça t'as pas de petite soeur
et deux petits frères gille qu'un chien
j'aimerais bien voir mon petit frère
marc veut pas pourquoi je veux pas parce
que tu lui as demandé pourquoi n'en est
pas pareil voudrait oui
d'un petit effort mais je vais écrire
pour tuer un petit frère je connais
l'usiné fabrique pas s'effacer étonnant
alors qu'est-ce que tu es grand pour
cinq ans je vais voir ton papa s'il est
aussi grand il est très bien à paris d
antan papa est plus petit toit tourner
les tout petits il est très grand
combien il mesure 5 mètres
5 c'est un monsieur vous devez avoir du
mal à vous habiller en confection ton
papa mesure 5 mètres est ta maman si m
et bien dites moins chère madame
voilà une grande famille alors dit
bonjour et tu as un frais non tu es tu
as pas frères pas de soeur et vous êtes
une grande fille tu as un chien et
combien il mesure 6 francs cinquième sur
six francs
un chien qui mesure 6 francs ah ben ça
alors je vais vous dire une chose et une
famille qui m'intéresse pas le mans est
ce que c'est la première fois que tu
rencontres de davos khoury et que tu la
vois pour de vrai alors comment tu la
trouves est atone avis combien il mesure
6 mètres aussi bien et bien mesdames
messieurs les anglais ont modifié
également leur système elle mesure 100
francs oui nous aurons beaucoup plus que
le chien oui à bâle cherche
effectivement là il ya quelque chose que
je comprends pas qu'est ce que tu as
dans la main
une galette et pour elle elle l est pour
qui la galette pour moi parce que moi je
pensais qu'il allait me le fais à l'est
pas pour moi si alors pourquoi tu la
manges c'est comme ça tu me laissera un
peu trop tard tu peux continuer à aller
bien dans un bel état il a grignoté les
chalets qui peut continuer à manger
[Musique]
dako rien mais quelles sont les banques
qui ont des tubes d'hier à la galette
elle est lé boss ses fans la gare est
due à m'offrir
oui c'est la tâche de la manger tu vas
les un peu c'est une galette que tu as
acheté pour moi louis portal est gay
c'est sûr pour moi tous les deux oui
alors ça c'est ma part c'est les miettes
ma ba tu veux pas garder ma part de
galette parce que je sais pas ce qui
s'est passé mais le marchand elle était
comme ça quand tu l'as acheté il ya
alors qu'est-ce qui manque qui sait
qu'il a mangé ouah non c'est pas de
galettes scène couronne est pour toi
devant la veille oh lalalalalalalalala
[Musique]
je veux pas tomber tu es tu proviens
l'intelligent aux maisons tôt je ne
savais pas moi
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui me fait rire
j'ai une grosse tête et ferrer car au
vent moi j'ai vraiment oui où tu vois
que je revends tu vois pas qu'est ce que
tu veux faire quand tu seras grand
stéphane foulé quoi rouler qu'est ce que
c'est un poulet il polit qu'est ce que
tu veux avant tu seras en batiste de
caen n'y a pas tord mais au fait
qu'est-ce que c'est un homéopathe scène
certains cas comme eto'o
pourquoi elle et pas pareil que les
autres parce que hilton pas
d'antibiotiques que gatti santé et une
idée suisse il est des choses naturelles
pourquoi mnr n'ont pas pas besoin
d'ennemis tués et dix toujours tu
t'appelles tu te dis ne veux pas que tu
parles là et pourquoi pas ce qu'est et
pourtant tu parles bien d'amateurs du
des bêtises et n'est pas vrai mais c'est
même pas vrai dit des bêtises tu dis pas
de bêtises mais non tu dis pas de
bêtises si tu dis des bêtises
qu'est-ce qui fait besoin comme métier
il est évident qu'on y lévy peau et en
faut un
qu'est ce que c'est un wibaut m'a ébahi
roche les pots de chambre
vous êtes range l'entrepôt de chance ça
c'est un métier formidable ça arrange
reprochant voilà métier comme il nous en
faudrait là j'ai compris je travaille
dans un hôpital à la vous occuper des
malades alors lui il dit la vérité c'est
vrai vous faites tout ce qui est le plus
difficile à faire vous occuper des eaux
vives pau et c'est à meetic un avantage
comme ça vous serez jamais dans le
besoin qu'est ce que tu vas chanter
j
mais non c'est pas grave
[Musique]
outre m
euh mon pantalon ic ir pop
taku n'en a pas sur mes chaussures si je
monte comme ça ouais ça se voit pas du
tout à fait pipi
puis tu sais les chaussures ça va sécher
non ça c'est je crois pas c'est des
chaussures en bois
c'est des chaussures en carton oui
écoute quand je t'ai vu arriver comme
secteur c'est ton c'est la première fois
que tu mets des pantalons longs oui oui
c'est un beau costume ça qu'est-ce qui a
acheté ça il sait qu'il peut acheter le
costume ou la page ternois donné et qui
ce qui vous la donner quelqu'un qu'on
connaît pas là bas non rouge
[Musique]
c'était le petit garçon oui mais si oui
s'appelle frédéric qui s'appelle papa
will et ba ba ba oui toute la famille il
en rouge il est jeune papa qu'elle agit
là comment il s'appelle le papa frédéric
gibert qu'elle agit là bas
le ta 25 ans et maman de l'âge est là
24 ans est ce que parce que maman
travaillent et gagnent à la maison c'est
du travail à la maison parce que 10 dont
il faut faire les lits il faut faire
laver s'intitulait d'un petit peu a pas
aidé mais joli
il oublie pas là parce que c'est tout
c'est tout le monde peut oublier
oui mais tu pourrais l'aider un petit
peu près de 10
il
de marineking windows mailhes heather
mills blonde maman et papa du pape à la
vang beaucoup de bien aux pays bas oui
ma maman la wii arrive à français waouh
ben oui je me trouve honda toi habitent
ou à potins sinon suis quelquefois bah
oui qu'est-ce que tu vas chercher là bas
mon papa il travaille ensuite et des
fonds à apporter déjeuner oui tu en fais
déjà un peu de sport non cac d'ici qui
as-tu fait du cycliste c'est bien ça tu
as une bicyclette ya as-tu fait du
cyclisme sans musique let ça c'est assez
étonnant alors et qu'en vélo et là deux
roues où il a plus de deux roues deum
émana 4
c'est plus facile hein et oui mais les
gains quand j'avais une paix que j'avais
une [ __ ] est là quand j'avais des
pédales et passer les quelques côtés du
côté l'autre côté du terrain hier péter
comme ça puis après comme je faisais
encore du vélo urbain la [ __ ] corps
intérieur une histoire
vous voyez c'est intéressant le fait
qu'il est gay c'est un film porno j'ai
rien filmé bordeaux c'est quoi ça je les
regarde oui quel est le quel est le
dernier film bordeaux tu as vu à la télé
le film porno que tu aimes le mieux à la
télé des garçons comme bordeaux je peux
te poser une question le journal
télévisé c'est porno oui je m'en doutais
que tu regarde le journal télévisé des
fois
qu'est ce que tu en penses toi des
hommes politiques ces deux messieurs en
costume noir avec des cravates noires
qui parle à la radio au moment du
journal
tu as dû voir ça voilà quelqu'un qui ne
s'intéressent pas encore la politique
c'est très bien mais tu t'intéresses à
la chanson we dit bonjour tu n'as fait
une grosse bise
comment tu le trouve bon marierait avec
qui
j'ai déjà amoureuse de lui il ya
longtemps
depuis combien de temps bien heureuse de
pierre bachelet
[Musique]
tu lui as écrit d'amour il n'a jamais
répondu
pour quand même tu exagères cinq ans
mais je veux te voir avec avec avec 111
tout à l'heure sur repent pas un an et
demi maintenant vous avez fait
connaissance à voilà oui faut que tu
attends tu peux avoir la patience
atteint j'attendrai combien de temps à
peu près un petit peu petit peu oui tu
attendras quoi elle va faire une bise à
l'autre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pourquoi tu embrasses et le petit
garçon tu connaissais avant d'en vidéo
car alain bize parce que tu le trouve
beau oui vous êtes marié avec j'ai peint
pas ton micro je parle à mon micro à ma
part ce sont les grosses parts c'est la
première fois que mme chantal goya ou à
ton avis laquelle
on a tout le temps
[Musique]
et tu viens au nord un kyste udine à
balma embrasser les machinistes en
coulisses il n'y a pas de papa lé là
embrasse un autre machiniste ne m'en
voulez pas non mais laissez là elle te
trouve sympathique c'est normal on
m'attend ballon on a le temps
et si tu veux que je fasse est-ce que je
commande mois dans cette émission on n'a
pas les noms habana dit non mais non pas
seulement un touriste voilà bah
maintenant à oublier personne
voilà tahltan chantal non parce que si
le sommet embrasser la salle on est là
pour un moment
voilà l'angoissé le caméraman voilà
le berceau
or le câble man aval c'est un moment en
bleu là comment c'est son petit nom
jordanie et en papa ticket n'est pas
peur sans rien du tout c'est une ampoule
capter des enfants c'est une folle non
sérieux tout ça fêtards s'y colla roux
qui nous a fait des bêtises
eh bien nous allons si vous le voulez
bien
écoutez notre petit eric qu'est-ce qui
change le petit eric faye a de quoi
d'ailleurs mis au point son tambourin
guillaume tu as chanté ça qu'il est
marrant tambourin sais pas ce qui était
prévu c'est pas ce qui était prévu ça
fait rien matra tard et ont besoin de
savoir c'est ce qu'on avait répété
qu'est-ce qu'on avait on n'avait pas
changé ça tout à l'heure
qu'est-ce qu'on avait chanté c'est ça
qui y menant tambour à un an tu veux pas
chanter alors tu veux chanter large
réseau important nouri veux pas chanter
la marche déjà rangée d
ils ont chanté une branche d ange tu
n'aimes pas la base des anges
non non il est pas l'argent mis à
chanter
qu'est ce tu veux chanter néanmoins tout
en vous réveillant breton tamboura de
charlas un tour allez vas-y champ est-ce
que tu parles un petit peu à monsieur le
maire que tu connais une chanson gracias
tu peux me chanter we are est fort vers
[Musique]
internet pour informer
voilà je vais
j'ai eu l'impression que ta mère sucer
son pouce pendant que tu chantais je l
avais un doigt dans la bouche elle
faisait comme ça il faudra lui tient à
coeur les noms
ah bon c est sur les dents c'est vrai on
donne aux sondés sur dix on la savait
tout à pierrelatte chansons mais le
pianiste avait pas une méthode
[Applaudissements]
et pinces et gendarmes il a gâché son
mail à venir
[Musique]
c'est formidable
sept ans c'est bien de rire parce que tu
sais attentive à la chanter on va
chanter avec bien michel viens on va
l'aider un peu parce que moi je vais te
dire tu ris comme jamais j'ai vu rire
alors on va laroche hanter un petit peu
vas-y visite a envie de rire tu rigoles
ce et cce qui te font rien ils sont
marrant hein
c'est marrant les grandes personnes dont
le teint mat et les trouve nombreux donc
les trouvent les grandes personnes et
pas bien le borgne
oui pas bien ça c'est ce que je vivais
où il vous trouve moches
thème mieux les enfants
oui pourquoi qu'est ce que tu reproches
aux grandes personnes mal pour un terme
et parent et puis événements
pareil c'est son droit ben j'ai bien eu
droit quand même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]